usual but magnus is not trying to use
world championship match preparation it
was clear that the time times are
calling for for serious measures
and we are seeing the catalan on the
board and after bishop before check
bishop d2 a5
magnus is thinking it's it's quite to
their line this this a5 it's it's
certainly something that liam tries to
get magnus out of his prep
bishop g2 of course okay if if black
takes on c4 actually we we might get
some very traditional
uh transposition
to traditional catalan lines but black
ops for short castle first
maybe not black takes on c4 yeah and if
uh you make a move like you want to
protect with queen c2 the pawn on c4
then probably black plays c5 as as you
mentioned yeah it's uh very cool yeah
this is queen c2 c5 stuff it's just a
very fascinating line but this is
different he went for a3 pushing the
bishop away the bishop falls back and
now queen c2
yeah now queen c2 i mean there is more
clarity in the position
knight bd7
well to be honest
i have been playing quite some
catalan also from white side also from
black side of course
but but this one when i was playing the
catalan with white this line simply did
not existed yeah and so i don't know
exactly all the latest developments here
magnus to go all out in this one with
the white pieces and uh what's the
update
yeah that's exactly what he's doing so
we had ac bishop e7 queen c2 knight b7
on the board bishop f4 c6 castles a4
knight c3 i mean
one also has to mention that yeah there
are like two ways of playing the catalan
in against this so-called orthodox
clause catalan that with some positional
matters or by brutal force that you
sacrifice the pawn and go for very
double-edged possessions
and of course
given the match situation magnus
actually has a very easy choice
to make because he knows exactly that he
has to go for the uncompromising
fighting choice and
i usually you know because i had those
type of positions from from the queen's
indian and even there this queen's
indian catalan transpositions it was
always very very dangerous for black and
you had to know your stuff very well and
it's such a rich position this is so
complex the ideas that we were
discussing white has sacrificed the pawn
he's gotten e5 in placed his knight on
e4 going for the king side attack
doesn't care about the material and take
a look at black's pieces the queen is
stuck on a6 the rook is stuck on it
it feels like white's gotten everything
that he wants out of the opening
yeah exactly there is also this very big
twist that by putting this pawn on a4
very very quickly actually black doesn't
have this typical counterplay with b5
before
and magnus is also coming very quickly
now with h5 he sacrificed the pawn
he's trying to break
black's construction yeah queen e2 so
basically he wants to provoke g6 after
which he wants to use the
wants to use the dark squares
you can also try to use the h file i
mean black species are so far away that
i'm what exactly peter i was just
wondering that a move like g4 and you
blast open the h file it just looks like
black is going to be super late to the
defense uh the idea of going rookie
three because knight is never
moved because of knight f6 check yeah
black plays the move h5 h4 yeah it's the
only
only move in the position
but bishop takes h4
yeah just trying to keep the h file
still as uh
as close as possible and b4 i like this
approach peter trying to make everything
out of the time that he's gotten because
c3 watch out c3 in the air trying to
trade the queens a little bit strange
with the pawn on a4 but of course yeah
the problem is that white is simply not
reacting anymore
bishop g7 and and also there he's in in
a complete mating net
i mean he takes a3 i won't even be
surprised if magnus just ignores the a3
pawn or i don't know if that's too much
but even a move like queen h3 comes to
mind magnus goes knight f6
yeah take stakes this is your position
this is what we've been discussing right
and he doesn't even care about the a3
pawn what's happening on the king side
on the queen side he's saying you can
take the house there i'm coming for your
king bishop f6 a takes b two beta let's
have a look at this line a little slowly
now um also you have queen f4 queen f4
threatening rook h3 yeah that's that
that's the other idea yeah this and this
yeah it should be made magnus actually
goes for qdhd so he goes for my original
stuff
bishop g7 we were just having a look at
this incredible line it is on the board
peter you called this one out bishop g7
played and here you wanted to get the
rook into the attack
i mean this is just he goes bishop e4 ah
okay yeah so he muggle just wants to go
king g2
and checkmate like this
okay black has to play c5 probably yeah
king g2 bishop b7 f3 ah maybe f3 c3
yeah i mean uh
at least i wanted to you know to somehow
open up the diagonal that i get access
to to this king such a mating net for
for black's king however
liam has opted for queen b5 so he's
trying some queen b3 destruction
okay so that's something uh how does
white does white go king g2 queen b goes
for g5 you always have these books yeah
bishop h6 i mean bishop g7 queen h6 and
then look look to the h file and it's
checkmate so if queen b3 right now yes
exactly so after queen b3 you can't go
rookie 3 because the rook on d1 hangs
can we take a look at that queen b3 on
the board on the board and i think
magnus will now make his move
and he just doesn't care i mean black is
in such a yeah bishop b7 so king g2 will
be met by c5 well look h1 is still a
mating threat yeah it's such a box yeah
just unbelievable what the box it is
it's insane this attack that he's built
on the king side which can just allow
him to give up all pieces just needs a
queen and a rook of course yeah magnus
goes for d5 or of course you you don't
even have to sacrifice the queen on h8
queen h7 check will be the same after
luke h1 and after ed5 look h1
and and okay the checkmate is coming
no matter how you prefer it yeah so
magnus actually seems to be bouncing
back in style with a crushing victory
and i'm down to 40 seconds already only
40 seconds and clock is not the problem
it looks like the kind of position where
even if you have one hour you're not
surviving this one yes yes even if one
week or one month yeah
no no we're not gonna see that moment we
might rook h1 coming in next peter
yes but after okay maybe it's not time
to
time to call it today rook hitch one on
the board this is the moment of truth
is liam going to throw in the towel he's
on to 20 sec i don't see a move actually
defending the mate yeah and he resigned
yeah correct and he resigned so